[Musique]
le mois d'août est synonyme de rentrée
pour les étudiants réunionnais si les
cours ont déjà repris dans les
amphithéâtres de l'université de la
réunion la campagne d'inscriptions elle
se poursuit jusqu'au 31 août passage
obligé pour les néo bachelier les stands
d'information où se trouvent notamment
celui du département alors on est venus
là pour informer les étudiants de des
aides du département que des partages de
discours pas tous les dispositifs d'être
que propose deux départements en
direction des étudiants alors faut
savoir si concerne les étudiants de
barcus jusqu'à 22,5 à le premier critère
bien sûr sur les ressources à savoir
chez vous il est quand même 2 86 euros à
lui un an si les parents ne les accepte
pas dépassera le plafond de 80 civils
les étudiants en formation initiale
peuvent prétendre à cette aide les
étudiants ont la possibilité de
constituer ou renouveler leurs dossiers
pour la location de scolarité ou encore
le dispositif net bourse jusqu'au 30
décembre prochain
[Musique]